e
e e
clb committee work session on um hb1
1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps uh we are
expecting one member who is going to be
arriving probably in 15 minutes or so uh
I'm going to recess the um hearing until
that point and uh hope that we uh have
better attendance by then thank
you
e
e e
um reopening the work session on HB
1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps uh and let's
just do a um budget of Al Allegiance
before we get started
uh would you like
to to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liy Justice for
All so uh I'm just going to present a
brief summary here of um I think well I
we pretty much know what the bill is
about but um when we uh had our hearing
on it uh we decided that we are going to
um send it to interim study because
um we heard a fair amount of testim
testimony indicating that it was a real
problem but we also heard testimony
suggesting that the uh solution that the
bill proposed was not uh workable as it
stood uh so interim study the interim
study is to uh essentially figure out if
there is a um a more workable solution
and then uh decide if we want to
recommend that solution for uh for the
legislation uh and the procedure is that
um so we'll have our discussion today in
committee uh and we'll probably be able
to uh be at a point at the end of the
work session today where we can vote as
a sub committee to say we will um we
recommend or don't recommend further
legislation and then that recommendation
will go to the full committee and when
the full committee work meets to uh
to vote on all of our interm study bills
then that
um that recommendation will be um
brought forward at that at that full
committee
meeting so just as a um a point to
consider as I understand uh the
something like glue traps are not under
the perview of the pesticide review
board in the state because it's a
non-chemical
uh um solution to dealing with rodents
is that correct I believe that's correct
okay thank
you so um this representative Duty was
not able to make it today because she
had to um take her husband to medical
appointments uh but she did uh suggest
one one possibility would be uh having
or requiring some language on the trap
on the traps at the point of sale which
would uh say one or two of the following
things um warning glue traps are known
to in trap and kill unintended wildlife
and pets use of this project product May
incur legal liabilities or warning glue
traps are considered inhumane and are
known to entrap and kill unintended
wildlife and pets use of this product
May incur legal liabilities so uh one
one approach would be simply requiring
that labeling at the point of sale I
don't know what the mechanics of that
would
be thank you
um
so because of
past issues that have been brought
before our committee with labeling we
know that requiring any labeling on any
product will essentially prohibit that
product from the state of New Hampshire
um because we are just a
minute
um buyer in right in the scheme of
things so I I think by requiring that I
mean we went through this with the GMO
labeling and everything else and we had
discussed that those products would just
no longer be sold in New Hampshire and
that's why that was not a viable option
and so to do that you would be
prohibiting the sale of uh glue traps in
New Hampshire so I don't believe that
labeling requiring labeling in the state
of New Hampshire is a viable
option um that's a that's a good point
that you bring up but I was I remember
that you had brought in uh packaging and
it had already stated on the label that
this product should not be used Outdoors
and that was the primary reason was
because they didn't want the
manufacturer did not want um an intended
non-targeted uh animals or or reptiles
or whatever insects or whatever to be
caught in these glue traps I believe
that there was labeling on these
products
already I don't believe it prohibited it
from being outdoors but it was very
specific as to where they should be
placed um because if you prohibit it
from being outdoors then you prohibit it
from barnyards from the barn um so you
know I believe that it should be I think
it's more specific like an enclosed area
not just outdoors and and as we heard
testimony nobody is going to place it
outside because the dirt's going to get
on there and it's going to make the glue
the adhesive ineffective I mean anything
gets on there it becomes ineffective as
as a means to trap the road
in representative
Haskins yes good morning well I don't
think that labeling is going to work so
that's the reason why I'm not going to
be supportive of that I'm working on a
bill about that has to do with alcohol
use disorder and um as a co-sponsor of
the bill we wanted something to go home
with each purchase of alcohol that
didn't fly so what we got was a video
message in all the liquor stores I've
not talked to anyone that's ever seen
who's gone into the liquor store the
video message um so yeah I mean I I'll
say more about what I think we should be
doing but I don't think labeling is
going to be
effective so um okay
mommy thanks um I also think that
um representative Duty added the part
about uh liability that that was that
was not would not have been implied or
included in the labels or the
descriptions of use that we saw on the
labels that you brought on the products
that you brought in and um I think that
that that that would certainly send a
stronger message about
usage thein thank you but the problem
with that is the enforcement right um um
we'd all like to think that liability
matters to producers and consumers as
well but if there's not sufficient
enforcement it just is
empty and and I'll add a comment here
which is that
um the uh we know that in the realm of
that for uh licensed PES pest uh
applicators the label is the law uh and
in fact that is also the case for
consumers but most consumers don't
realize that the label is the law and
there are many consumers who are not
particularly good about reading the
labels so uh I'm I'm I think that is
another uh another aspect of you know
making labeling not necessarily as
effective as as as it might be so um but
represent H Haskins has mentioned she
has an an alternative idea to that so
maybe we could hear that
now thank you yes I went back and looked
at the testimony that we received when
the bill was aired and
um at the time I said that glue trap
seemed to me to be a 19th century
solution to a problem and surely in the
21st century we should be able to come
up with something more humane and
equally effective and so I learned about
contraception for rodents which I had
not previously known about um I just
want to suggest also that in reviewing
the materials I noted that fish and game
is opposed to glute traps because they
catch non-target wildlife such as song
birds and
snakes aabon was concerned because um
the rodents who take this lethal dose of
Rosen
rodenticide become prey for Hawks owls
weasels foxes Fishers and other small
mammals so you know second generation
rodenticides are more lethal that's why
they're second generation than the
previous ones were so contraception for
rodents um I guess has been out there
for a while I hadn't heard about it
previously but I did talk with a company
called senis
Tech and we had quite a long discussion
about the fact that this is approved by
the state it's um sold at Amazon now
it's coming to Ace Hardware and farm and
feed stores it's basically a sausage
bait it's a
non-lethal method of uh controlling
fertility in
rodents and it's apparently very
effective in
the um places where it's been used more
extensively like California and other
places
um rodents mature quickly and have many
litters yes every six weeks
possibly um so this um
contraception is as I say um
non-lethal reasonably
affordable
and I think first of all with anything
environmental we have to start with
mitigation whether I'm talking about
landfill or plastic or whatever it is
the
first case should be you know cleaning
up the area making sure the food's not
left out all the things that I hope
would be common sense to most people so
you start with m ation but that's not
been enough um and by the way I wanted
to say that the um pest control people
um did indicate to us at the time that
there was no alternative to
rodenticides this is the
alternative I didn't know about it at
the time but
um yeah so I'd like to hear thoughts
about this um
they
um since these
um rodenticides are
poison they um can get in the food chain
and
ecosystems and I I really think that
their
exposure to um all manner of pets the
unintended consequences the non-target
animals is perhaps the chief reason why
it seemed unacceptable to me that that's
the best solution we could come up
with thank you
um when for mosquitoes that carry
diseases they use they use
contraceptives a lot and me that's one
of the ways that they keep the
population down in places um so it can
be effective I just don't think it's
it's immediately effective but but you
know one one at a time traps are not are
probably not any faster than
contraception so I I would imagine I
don't know but representative Aaron
thank
you I have a couple thoughts on that
um well first um
with with um
contraception I mean on its face it
sounds like a really good idea but I
would worry about upsetting the um the
food chain for I mean if you're going to
if you're going
to ostensibly eradicate the ability of
uh rodents to
reproduce What will that do to the
population that's available for hawks
and birds of prey and other animals that
do eat those and I mean yes there is a a
portion of them that may be
poisoned um but there's a probably a
great G portion that are not and I I
would I would worry that it would
disrupt make a big disruption in in the
food
chain uh overall so um representative
Duty sent me an article from the Boston
Globe uh about the about um rodent uh uh
contraception and
the
uh
the sort of boiled down to the basic
conclusion is that uh it sometimes has
some positive of effect but is not you
uh does not does not completely you know
get rid of populations uh one of the one
aspect of it is that
um with as with human
contraceptive uh through pills uh
depends on it being taken on a regular
basis so if they only take the bait that
has the contraception in it
intermittently then it's not going to be
as effective um and uh we also know that
uh contraception the the the pill does
not always work so uh and my upstairs
neighbor has a grandchild because the
pills not always work so um if I may uh
so uh I actually am not quite finished
with this thought but uh one of the
things that the article pointed out was
that uh a potential issue is that uh
that might create selective pressure for
the for the rodents that don't
particularly like the type of bait U
because uh because the uh if you reduce
the reproduction of all the ones who
like that bait then the ones who don't
like that bait are then going to
predominate in the population uh so I
don't see it as being an issue with the
entire po population being wiped out I I
do see it see it as being something that
may be a mix in a larger in in a larger
set of approaches but probably does not
actually it's not going to be the Silver
Bullet well it definitely is another
tool in the toolbx for sure um and and a
non
um you know poisonous or
one but I also have a followup um with
regard
to the point about
capturing non-targeted species I mean if
these glue traps are indeed used indoors
as they are supposed to be they are not
supposed to be used Outdoors where they
would trap birds or uh turtles or you
know small turtles or snakes or whatever
um I mean I think that's the
problem that perhaps the Autobon society
and others may be seeing is that the
improper use of these glue traps is what
causing is what's causing the the Trap
entament of non-targeted species but I I
would also reiterate the point of the
value of having a non-chemical means of
eliminating rodents which is very much
used in the food industry and um on
farms in barns in enclosed areas uh and
in other places that
uh you know glue traps make sense to use
so I'm just pointing that out yeah thank
you we're talking about human behavior
avior right it's just like the labeling
issue you know you can tell people what
they should be doing whether they do it
or not I mean we have so much testimony
from all these Wildlife
associations of reptiles birds kittens
all manner of squirrels foxes
so The
lethality is the poison is the part of
it that strikes me as untenable that we
ought to be able to
increase knowledge awareness of
mitigation you know the all the simple
essential oils all the things that we
wish people would do to start with
removing the food supply all of that is
mitigation but I do agree that a tool in
the toolbox might
make a forward motion in terms of
reducing ing the rodent population
through a non-lethal means which appeals
to me representa compa thank you very
much
um when we're talking about glue traps
we I think we need to understand that
rodenticides are not part of the glue
trap uh they're two separate
issues um and glue traps are
non are not poison they're
non-toxic
um I was just at a farm bureau meeting
um a week ago literally and we were
talking about this subject because my
job is to bring to up What legislation
you know is happening in
conquered and when I told
them about this bill and trying to ban
the glue
traps they were like you
can't um and I'm like well this is what
we're hearing in conquer
um because and we did talk about birth
control and how it has been effective in
some areas in helping control the
population so that was also a topic of
discussion um we also talked about uh
second generation rodenticide which I
believe the EPA is going to be making a
ruling on fairly quickly so that will
not be an Arsenal for the homeowner so
that's coming off the table so you're
already taking a tool off
glue
traps very rarely affect
Wildlife it's not I don't believe the
impact is there that the second
generation rodenticide is where that is
a huge problem for the Wildlife I mean I
won't even use it because of my dogs
okay but we have to understand that when
you're dealing with
Farmers I mean we have seed we have food
we we have to store this stuff in order
to be viable farmers and we do they do
the best they can to store it in
containers but it still attracts the
rodents
and although I think contraception is
another alternative and something in our
toolbox we're already pulling a tool off
the table that we have to have
non-lethal uh for
Animals tools that we can that can be
used we we can't we have to think about
all everything not just different
segments and when you're talking about
the people that actually supply the food
that we eat we have to give them the
tools to make sure that they're being
able to control the problem
too representa
Howard um it seems like we could we
could rank these um the options as far
as toxicity and and the ripple effect of
of that they have on Wildlife on on
human safety and stuff like that and it
seems that it if every one of them is
used according to the directions you
know the pesticides and the and the um
the glue traps and the contraceptions it
seems like we we're on the verge of
ruling out the pesticides because the
ripple effect is is great with wildlife
and and and pets and stuff like that um
it seems to me that if used according to
the directions that um the farmers need
the glue traps and and I I imagine they
are inclined to use them according to
the directions because they don't want
their other animals stuck in them um and
that the contraceptions are a good
complement to that because it it reduces
the the number of of animals that are
susceptible to to be causing problems
and and stepping on the Trap so um also
to uh represented eron's point about the
um lowering the food chain availability
of it's only it's only verman who go
into your barn right or into your into
your house that would be susceptible to
these uh to this solution so I think
that the ones who stay out in the field
and do their Wild Thing are still
available to foxes and Hawks um and I I
can I can on my little acreage um
there's plenty of those so
um so um I'm going to sort
of uh up until fairly recently like last
fall I didn't have any rats in my um on
my property and that was I considered
myself lucky
and then some appeared uh and at F at
first they were just in the wood storage
shed and in the around the chicken cpop
and uh and I thought okay well I'll just
you know put out traps and you know and
I would get you know a one or two
trapped every week and that's you know
does a little bit to the population but
not it certainly is not eradicating them
uh and then I noticed that they were
getting into the crawl space in the
house and at that point I thought okay
this is beyond my skill set probably uh
and I'm going to call a professional so
I called a professional who came out and
looked at the looked at the setup looked
at you know the the extent of the garden
and the Orchard and the chicken Coupe
and the fact that the chickens are free
free range um they just fly over the
electric fences so they they're free
range whether I can try to contain them
or
not so um and uh she said there are so
many food sources out here that uh uh
that is going that there's going to be a
lot of difficult y getting them to eat a
bait and uh so the bait the poison baits
whether the desant or the uh escar are
not going to be useful in this situation
furthermore because you have chickens
out there even if you put the um the
escar in and clothe spaces in the house
rats carry them around so they may end
up at in the yard and that would not be
good for that would be a potential
problem for the birds so she ruled that
out um and then she said your best bet
is going to be
trapping with uh traps that are only
intermittently fire rings so that you
can train them to think the food is safe
and then it's not uh which doesn't
include glute traps I asked about glute
traps she
said um for rats they're pretty useless
the rats are just going to k kick dust
onto them and then do whatever they want
so
so uh so that basically means that you
know glue traps are really pretty much a
solution just for mice that are going to
be running you know Running Blind you
know fairly carelessly along runways
next to the wall and are not going to be
they're not particularly useful for rats
um which so uh which doesn't mean that
they're not useful for mice so but I
think that uh
might be some sort of a room for for
increasing the requirements that they
only be used in enclosed
areas so I think we're all hopeful that
the FDA will come out with some I assume
[Music]
um
greater uh warnings or elimination even
of second generation denti sdes I think
we we have the information out
there so for
this other
idea what I'm hearing is perhaps this is
as Judy said the tool in the toolbox to
add to mitigation efforts which in my
view you know should be happening as
well um so reducing a mice population is
perhaps one way to um add to the
other um less lethal um or at least more
effective you know I mean I'd love to
have them be effective and non-lethal
right that would be a perfect scenario I
don't know how we get
there but I was excited about this
methodology because I can see that it
would be you know helpful um I've sent
for this product going to give it to my
kids whove bought The Farmhouse because
I don't think they have the first idea
what they're up against um so I can
report later on you know how effective
it is um but yeah I think that's what I
where I think we're
at okay so do you um
what do you envision in terms of
legislation for this is this something
that for which legislation is
appropriate at this point or or is it um
or is it something where um just having
the information about the the
contraception more available would be um
would be what we
need well you know I don't know how
effectively we can distribute the
information or ask that it be um part of
the places the purveyors of traps and of
all
kinds
um let's let's hear what our colleagues
have to
say um so as far as the
contraception um I think that you know
knowing that we even just had that
discussion at my Farm Bureau meeting
that people are are now talking about it
means the information is getting out
there but if maybe we could get um you
know places like the Farm Bureau to say
here's an alternative or um maybe put it
on somewhere on a website that this is a
new product that is now an alternative
um for helping with your rodent
population I think it's more about
getting the information out but
obviously uh the fact I didn't know I
mean we talked about contraception here
in our committee but then listening to
the conversation at our Farm Bureau
meeting means that people are hearing it
now from you hearing that it it's
readily for sale on Amazon you said so
now the you know big retailers are now
starting to sell that so you're starting
to see that um and if that goes well you
probably start seeing it in the big box
stores or something to that or your
Agway or things like that so I think
that the more discussions you start
hearing about means that the information
is already getting out there um so
that's a positive sign um and maybe
organizations like I said the Farm
Bureau or something can start putting
things
out yeah I I recall when um the
Department of Agriculture had that uh
farm and uh Forest fair in um I think it
was in Dearing earlier this um earlier
this year there actually was a vendor
there that had um a rodent uh
contraceptive product that she was
selling and so I do think that that is
uh an upand cominging uh method that
people are going to become more aware of
and you know with any of these things I
really do
think the the
whole um issue falls on public
education educating the public on what
are the different means available to
them if they're not using um a uh a
professional service to help them with
their rodent problem I think that you
know people are becoming more uh aware
of what their choices are and I do
believe that um because of you know
certain just even you know people don't
want to be cleaning out cleaning up
after glue traps I I don't think that
that's actually a very popular
means for a many people um there are
farmers that still use it for and and
also Food Service people who use it in
enclosed areas um what what the thing is
is again education for people to know
how to use these uh products properly
and um and that's I think our biggest
thing is is educating the public on how
to use these things
representative Howard um I agree with
everything that that um the other
Representatives have been saying I think
that um in terms of legislation this is
a ban so I think that we are not going
to forward this because we're I think it
seems like we're in agreement that that
um that it it's doesn't make sense for a
band so um I I just wonder um this might
may be a naive question but is there a
way to as legislators um you know
encourage a a campaign about the cont
cont you know an information campaign
about the contraception so that they
know that it that it's a a a valid tool
in the
toolbox so um one possibility would be
getting in touch with the department and
seeing uh whether the IPM program
includes this as part of their uh their
training for uh for people who are
getting pesticide
licenses uh and so that that would be
one way of doing it another another is
that the department does have certain
informational uh material on their
website uh and uh so we could uh contact
the commissioner and see if this is
something that the department might be
interested in in um in publicizing I
think it would be very similar to how
the Department of Environmental Services
has done an entire um public education
program to let people know you know not
to flush things down the toilet that is
not flushable because that damages the
municipal uh sew systems and so and so
forth so I mean there our agencies
already do do a lot of public education
in many different areas and I think this
is an area that perhaps the Department
of Agriculture um could pursue
representative thank you um I really
like the idea of um the IPM uh having
director Russo get involved uh and
disseminating this um but I also think
that if you
because I mean some homeowners probably
use the glue traps most people as we
heard in testimony and in even in just
talking with folks you know are are
varing away from them I mean it's
already people are already doing that
themselves um so I think it's it's more
in the
agricultural
uh sector that use because not one thing
works because they're Prett they they
they understand that if there's one
thing then they they switch their
behaviors so we have to be so you just
need different tools because you have to
switch things up uh in the Arsenal but I
think including uh asking the director
to include that into the integrated Pest
Management program uh represent Bixby is
a great idea
we will get
touch do you have your mic on
sorry all right just repeat that for for
the record so uh so I think it makes
sense for us to approach the department
in terms of including this in their
educational uh work and uh we probably
need to talk to commissioner Jasper who
will then uh uh hopefully direct
director Russo to um to work this into
the uh pesticide training uh information
and the IPM information
so specifically we would be asking them
to include um contraceptive means in the
IPM and also to direct people if they
are going to use glue traps that they
must use them in enclosed spaces yes
okay representative Howard and and uh
can we sort of formalize that we're not
that we don't recommend the the ban bill
that we um is is we've concluded is we
advance that to the back to the
committee right right so um let me just
uh did you have a specific uh piece of
legislation that you were thinking of or
that was going to work on this or did or
were were you more interested in
promoting the idea of the um
contraception well you know my goal was
frankly to ban glue traps that's there
just isn't support for it so um
obviously the education piece is
fabulous I mean why would we not do that
that that's a great idea but I didn't
have other legislation in
mind okay so um I think at this point it
might make sense to um take a uh a
committee a subcommittee vote for our
recommendation to the full committee uh
does anyone have a
motion would be a motion be to itl the
bill
be your choices are um recommend
recommend this legislation for future
legislation or not recommend for future
legislation I would make a motion not to
recommend is there a second okay second
and by representative Howard let me just
um
okay so the motion is
um uh do we need uh uh we can do this on
a Voice vote right okay so um anyone all
in favor u i
i I'll opposed uh no okay so
um so the
uh so our recommendation is to not
recommend for future legislation but
recommend uh but recommend that the
department provide educational material
both on glue traps and on
contraception
yes uh yes
certainly would it be helpful to also
include information about why not to use
second generation
rodenticides no it doesn't okay
yes yeah that's that's that's a separate
bill and uh just just just to um a a
little bit of more information on that
uh I didn't read it very carefully but I
did see a list of what the proposed new
regulations uh from the USDA on second
generation red genocides are uh
and the uh well they did not uh
recommend completely Banning them for
Homeowner use uh they uh they are only
allowing single use uh enclosed bait
stations for uh for public sale uh and
and then further uh and I don't remember
what the further restrictions for uh for
other sale and use were but but that's
the the rough uh roughly they were
reducing the amount of access that
owners can have it to it uh represent K
thank you um so my question is is um
just want to make sure when they do the
single use uh I'm I hate to assume
anything but usually when there's a
single use uh being done it's in an
enclosed thing so that the the rodent
will go into something grab that and it
will tra get trapped inside um so I'm
not sure if that's what they're thinking
as a single use
uh I don't I I did not read it carefully
enough to be able to answer that
question but I'm sure that the that it's
on the EPA
website and I think I misspoke the first
time when I said USDA it's the EPA
that's doing
that so um is there any more business uh
of the subcommittee okay all right so uh
this session is now
closed
e
e e